[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i have a few remarks i'm going to read
them because i want to make sure i
i hit the notes i wanted to hit so let
me just introduce kashona to you all
so kishona dr kishona gray is assistant
professor in communication
and gender and women's studies at the
university of illinois at chicago
she is a faculty associate at harvard's
berkman center
and was previously a recipient of the
mlk visiting professor position
here at mit so i think a number of you
got a chance to know cashona personally
if you hadn't before then
um she's also been a faculty visitor
with our friends down the road at
microsoft
new england the social media collective
casino is the author
uh or co-editor of numerous books and
articles including her foundational 2014
work
race gender and deviance and xbox live
2018's edited collections woke gaming
and feminism and play
and recently intersectional tech which i
was very excited to get my physical copy
of the other day
black users in digital gaming and she
also has a book currently under contract
with nyu
entitled black cyber feminism or how
intersectionality went viral which i
know
all of us are really excited for um
kashona is a highly sought after speaker
as i'm sure many of you know
and we're lucky to have her today and
she regularly addresses both academic
and industry audiences such as the game
developers conference
she's the winner of a number of awards
over the years most recently
the evelyn gilbert unsung hero award
from the academy of
criminal justice sciences and when i
read that i thought oh i think that
heroicness is increasingly sung and i
hope even more so
because she is an amazing scholar and
person
any of us who know kashona know that she
is not only a vibrant intellectual force
doing some of truly the best work out
there but one of the most generous and
collaborative people we've met
and i really say that from my heart um
let me just say a few more words about
the impact her research has been making
over the years i first met kashona
through our shared interest in gaming
and was really immediately struck
by how generative her work was it was a
really important
moment in my own intellectual trajectory
to engage with her research
and it has affected game studies in
profoundly important ways centering
issues of race
gender intersectionality and justice
she's inspired scholars both old and new
to expand what we're tackling and i i
really
feel like i mean especially i meet so
many junior scholars for whom kashona is
just such an important waypoint in their
trajectory and i think
i know i'm really grateful to have her
in the field for that
i consider her one of the key people
pushing the field and doing some of the
most
truly most important work out there
she's always beautifully balancing what
i think of as an attention to structures
of oppression and exclusion
but with the vibrant and lived ways
people resist survive and thrive and
that is a delicate balance to try to do
in in really good work i want to know
too that kashona
is as much a scholar of media and
technology as she is of games
she's written on social media as well as
critical theories of race and technology
i think she does an amazing job
situating games within a broader
conversation
and that is in fact one of the things i
so value about her work and
in fact i consider this most recent book
in particular and i'm going to show it
to plug it again
really a kindred to the kind of work
we're seeing from people like ruja
benjamin
andre brock and safia noble in their
recent monographs
so i really see her contributions as
vital not just for game studies and
people interested in games but anyone
thinking about critical media studies
and technology studies and so if you
can't tell i'm
a huge fan girl and very honored to be
able to introduce her today so
dr gray tia you're going to have me
crying
it thank you tl that was such a
beautiful and generous
introduct introduction um
i i think you know sometimes you know we
don't take like a moment and like sit
with you know like the impact that we
might have like
on on people and like on fields and i
think that was um
after hearing you know your words tl and
you know you've expressed this like
before like
i'm just i i often like say like i'm
just here so i don't get fined right you
know i'm just here doing the things just
so i can
you know get tenure and like i think i
get caught in like the
the routine of just like the academic
grind of like we're doing things okay i
did this to get a promotion we do this
like so i can be marketable i'll do this
so i can get a job
do this so i can get 10 you know and and
you know i think i
i had to just like stop for like a
moment and just like say hey
like i've especially with this book and
like how everybody is just like
like engaged with it and like it's just
like ella it's
it's really humbling you know i don't i
don't have any more words like beyond
that to just say that it's very
um humbling thank you so much um tl and
thank you you know to like the mit
community for um
inviting me like to to to come and share
and to learn from you all and
you know we learned from each other and
i think it was just like released like
such a i
i enjoy my time and i know it was a
stressful time you know like whenever
i was i was there and and it was one of
those things i didn't really like
take in like just like how significant
that moment
was like to be there like in that space
like you know and then whenever i tell
people they're like hey like you were at
mit for you i'm like yeah and in my mind
you know because you all are just like
regular ass people to me i'm like yeah
they're
they're like wait a minute you were
there you know like with these amazing
scholars these
like with sasha i'm like yeah sasha's
cold tl's cool like you know i think
i didn't like i i took it for granted
you know just how
powerful that time was and just you know
how much you all like you know thought
of me and my work like to be able to
join you all like in that space so
i'm i'm i'm forever grateful and i'm
humbled and and
the other thing you know um writing
books is interesting i'm gonna get to it
i'm so sorry i have so much to talk
about i need to like shut up and just
like just
get to what uh my words this is why i
have to write stuff down now i've
reached a point in my career where i
have to write it down because i just
started thinking about all these things
that i want to talk about
but i think this is something especially
like for junior folks people who are
like thinking about like writing books
and
you know like for students who are like
in this space it's so interesting
because you spend so much time
intimately like connected to this work
right like so i've been writing this
book
for a while now right and it's like out
there in the world and it's so brand new
for everybody
like for me like i'm ready to go on to
the next thing you know i don't want to
talk about the book anymore you know
um but you know so i always say that
because i still i don't know how to do
like a book talk i kind of approach this
as like a book talk so
you know what i'm gonna do it'll be like
an overview of like you know where i've
come from you know i can
give you like brief snippets like from
the book but i i also want to like talk
about let me share the screen
i also wanted to um let make sure i
share the right thing and i'm not sure
if you all will be able to see me still
hopefully you can still see me somewhere
on the screen
and you can see okay thumbs up thank you
thank you so much um
i was in the when i was thinking about
putting this
this talk together there was a quote
from it was like an accidental interview
that i did right so last summer
i started you know uh you know most of
you know i've got kids i've got two kids
you know they're seven and nine now so
we library hop right you know we spend
most of our days you know kind of like
exploring
the different libraries and we did that
while we were in boston you know we did
that like when we were in phoenix
and now you know there's like an amazing
network of like you know public library
so you know we spent some time you know
last summer you know we wanted to um
uh on the libraries like on the south
side and i was paying attention to these
young folks that were gaming right they
i don't think they were supposed to be
gaming but i think they had there was
like some planned programming they were
supposed to be doing but they had their
phones out right
and i could tell they were they were
playing fortnite in these phones right
and so
i started like these conversations like
with these with these young folks and
i just want to say you know just what
they were doing really was just so
uh such a powerful example of what i
mean by like this concept of inter
intersectional tech let me
let me let me get let me read this quote
right let me let me just also just read
what i've written intersectional tech
was born out of the desire to elevate
the innovative cultural production of
black users inside tech
often being touted as poster children
for the digital divide
the technical capabilities of black
folks are often overlooked
as they may not fit within traditional
modes of engaging with technology
now i'm not interested in exploring
reasons for the digital divide
my work could care less about the
digital divide why
because it begins from a deficit model
without ever
interrogating how marginalized folks may
engage differently because of a lack of
resources or lack of access
now moving away from this deficit model
of what people don't have
it is necessary to explore the ways
black users create hybrid
infrastructures
recognizing the importance of physical
and digital spaces
and their technological innovativeness
so i want to engage with this quote so
back here i told you all like this story
about me being at these libraries so i
started talking with these young folks
and this
quote stuck with me right ain't no
internet at home
ain't no wifi i stole this galaxy
if i wasn't here in the public library
there's no telling what i'd be doing
damn show wouldn't be fortnite at
hearing or reading these words
what might you first direct your
attention to now if i provide you with
the
additional context that this youth is a
he's a black boy he's from englewood
it's a neighborhood on chicago's south
side he's from a single parent household
his
older brother recently died from gun
violence
now traditional methods for researching
would automatically pathologize his
experience
the deficit deficit model would want to
engage the individual reasons for his
family's realities
maybe a concerned researcher wouldn't
want to engage the structural barriers
leading to his exclusion
some scholars would totally ignore these
realities and say that all he needs is
access to the internet that'll solve his
problems
some might focus on the criminal aspect
of stealing and trying to find resources
so he can avoid
this life of crime most of us would turn
on that white savior complex and
activate our white guilt and feel bad
for this kid because we have more
privileges than he does
what we would fail to do is explore how
in spite of all of this
this young human has found a way to
still participate
and engage in the space that gives him a
temporary break from his realities
the question that i immediately asked
myself when darius made this comment
was what could i learn from him
what can i learn from what he has
created and designed and constructed
and this question allows me to engage in
his realities it allows me to engage in
the structural barriers the
institutional oversight and the public
neglect
it also forces me to engage in his
intersecting identities
and this is intersectional tech through
this framework
i explore the ways that our identities
intersect with technological tools
artifacts and systems that have been
mobilized to draw connections between
digital
and physical spaces and realities gaming
has become the glue that binds my
projects where i explore
how black users engage with physical and
visual
textual and oral practices to illustrate
how gaming can be used as a catalyst
for educating and supporting other users
of digital technologies
gaming is often a medium that's outside
of conversations on blackness and
digital practices
and it's one that's becoming more
visible viable and
legible in making sense of black
technoculture
intersectional attack implores us to
make visible the force of discursive
practices
that position practices within
disorderly
social hierarchies and arrangements the
explicit formulations
of the normative order are sometimes in
disagreement with the concrete human
condition
as well as inconsistent with the
consumption and production practices
that constitute
black digital labor but also our
pleasure and our desires
so you know what intersectional tech is
but how did i get here
the development of this project has been
a decade in the making
but using the words of black creator
khalif adams in 202014 was the
proverbial backbreaking straw
read this quote i felt like both the
gaming space in the real world had hit
this level of toxicity
that was unsustainable and for the first
time in a long time
i didn't know what or how to express how
i felt about them
so i sat down thought about what good
could we do in the gaming space
how we could affect change in whatever
small way we could as an entity
then the eric garner incident happened
and it was the proverbial back-breaking
straw many black users around games
often remark that they have a moral
obligation
to serve their community and mobilize
their platforms for community support
especially because they just play games
take the death of eric garner by the new
york police department for example
eric garner succumbed to the state state
state sanctioned chokehold
by officer daniel pantaleo for selling
loose cigarettes
his death captured on video catapulted
the already invigorated
black lives matter movement often
signaled by the phrase i can't breathe
there was a plethora of responses to the
unarmed black men dying at the hands of
the police
including responses from the gaming
communities
khalif adams co-creator of the gaming
podcast spawn on me
stated that he wanted to use his gaming
and podcasting platforms to bring
awareness to deaths of the unarmed by
the police
his spawn for good initiative was one of
the first to censor gaming technologies
to discuss
black lives matter he used twitch to
stream messages about the racist
treatment of black people by law
enforcement
and generated funds to help the family
of eric garner cover burial cause
during the two-day event khalif also
provided information on other cases of
police abuse of power
including mike brown and ezell ford
there was constant backlash and
resistance by gamers who suggested that
twitch was not the platform
to express support for black lives
matter but khalif adams affirmed that he
streams for those who want to be the
change they wish to see in the world
i offer this example as one of many that
can be interrogated through a lens of
intersectional techno culture
while public discussions around gaming
culture often focus on the toxic
elements
negatively impacting the marginalized
there are thriving groups utilizing
online environments and their related
tools to sustain their communities
trolls and other toxic actors may
dominate certain conversations in public
and private spheres
however we must begin to focus on the
communities that black bodies in
particular create and sustain
gamers who live stream on twitch mixer
youtube i don't even think mixer is a
thing anymore while experiencing racism
and
harassment also expressed that they are
able to create networks of black gamers
streamers and others others
demonstrating the innovativeness
of black digital practices in gaming
context
from console to mobile gaming to
multiplayer
and streaming these spaces have become
increasingly transmediated
incorporating visual oral and textual
media
across technological forms of media the
concept of transmedia described the way
that new technologies have been used to
extend traditional mediated narratives
to other forms of media and takes into
account the shifting patterns of
movement
by both texts and audiences across
distinct but interrelated platforms
acknowledging the physical along with
the digital
utilized here i explore the complicated
relationship that black users have
within structures
and how they use these technologies to
recognize acknowledge and complicate the
role
that blackness has had in the everyday
practices and production of these users
hopefully this plays for you all
let's see i might have to go to
let's see
is that planned for you all somebody
give me a thumbs up okay perfect perfect
all right so take hair now for example
that's weird because all the screens are
like up there i don't know how to find
like my notes anymore but you also y'all
know here now
take care now for an example created by
momo pixel
hair naw allows players to customize an
avatar who can smack away as many white
hands as possible
as they attempt to touch locks twists
braids and relaxed black hair
the game quickly went viral both the
game and its residents captured a
convergence of powerful contemporary
racial and gender dynamics and histories
from black hair politics to the history
of white supremacy
as it relates to the hyper policing and
surveillance of black women's bodies
yet the game's power reflects its
rejection of these histories
and its embrace of a virtual and
physical clap back
the game's intervention centering of
blackness and embrace of resistance
all embodies the game's refusal of
erasure
from it from its conception to reception
hair now exemplifies the yearning for
transformative games
by centering the experiences of black
women the exis
existence of such a game let me make
sure to go here mobile pixel i want to
make sure we'll say her name she's the
creator of her gnome
by experience by centuring the
experiences of black women the existence
of such a game is disruptive
in itself as it illustrates the power
and potential to use video games
online technology and gaming culture to
highlight
the experiences of black women and other
marginalized communities
resisting and otherwise challenging
dehumanizing representation
now i come back to the concept of space
and making sense excuse me i come back
to the concept of space and making sense
of momo pixels contributions
space does not simply exist as a given
but it's constructed
and affects and is affected by those
with the most power
in this way space is not just a passive
backdrop to human behavior but social
and social action
but is constantly produced and remade
within complex relations of culture
power indifference
it is this rejection where scholars
offer a more critical constructionist
notion of space that informs my work
in an attempt to make plain the
importance of space
and the creation and construction of
black women's identities
more specifically this reflection
explores how black women make sense of
spaces that they occupy
especially that they are not that's not
traditionally crafted or constructed for
them
by interrogating the actual back and
forth travel from digital to physical
spaces that black women engage
we are able to see how they sustain
their identities
support social movements both online and
off in a form of discursive activism
so hair not can be viewed as a form of
discursive activism which refers to
speech
or texts that seek to challenge dominant
social discourse
by exposing flawed assumptions or
representing reality in order to rewrite
the norms and practices of society
nancy frazier considers discursive
politics as an essential strategy of
political resistance
this discursive activism disrupts the
sensibilities of sacred
symbolic space that has been constructed
and reimagined by those who restrict
black women's access into those spaces
now i explore the everyday practices of
excluding black women not in a
traditional sense or why black women are
excluded based on perceptions of
inferiority
but in the progressive landscape of
white women's feminism
anti-blackness black men's protectionism
for black women
that produces a particular kind of
domination where there is an idealized
notion of womanhood and blackness
and black women are not included
while not explicitly stated a lot of my
work provides this revisioning and
reimagining of black women's rage
which is typically viewed as a
destructive emotion offering no value to
modern society
lord offers a audrey lord excuse me
audrey lord offers
a compelling critique of rage and
engaging the useful aspects of this
emotion while also balancing its
limitations
the systematic devaluation of black
womanhood has given rise to not only
interracial oppression but intra-racial
practices of devaluation
and exclusion as well we continue to see
the proliferation of black women's
historical misrepresentation
repackaged in contemporary ways from
aunt jemima
to sapphire to the angry black woman
these caricatures of black women are
used in attempts to flatten the
complexity of black womanhood
simplifying the intricacies of black
women's anger sexualities and
relationships
and rehashing them as stereotypes to try
to attempt to control black women's
bodies
this demonization becomes dangerous as
these singular narratives delimit
societal engagement with black women
there's no holistic understanding of the
roots of these images
thus the anger that emerges from black
women in response to these controlling
images is loaded with information and
energy
the information and energies generated
from the rage among other emotions
provide black women with an arsenal to
transform the rage into advocating
for liberating and transforming the
disentrance disenfranchised experiences
of marginalized folks
and as audrey lord states we have to use
that anger
you know from audre lorde to bell hooks
their theorizing of black feminine rage
proves useful as a tool to weave through
the structures of oppression inside
gaming technologies
in these digital spaces crafted by black
women there is a process to engage with
the rage so often quelled by society
we have to undo the haunting of that
demonization
that came in response to our rage
suggesting that our anger has no
legitimacy
the black women within the work that
i've done within intersectional tech and
the previous um
work that i've done they mobilized their
rage in strategic ways
validating each other's feelings while
society deems them as destructive and
inappropriate
just as audrey lord bell hooks just as
they did in creating public spaces for
the expression of black female rage
especially in academic spaces
these women too create intersectional
counterpublics
their work inside the spaces of digital
gaming provides spaces to heal
the intersectional wounds and collective
traumas from white supremacy black
patriarchy white feminism and so many
others
these spaces validate the rage of black
women's experiences
and bell hooks asked the question why is
the rage of black folks about white
supremacy
made to appear ridiculous the centrality
of bell hooks's question adheres to the
necessity of black women's rage to
generate
the attention needed to begin making
structural changes to transform lives
black women in gaming deploy
storytelling critical theorizing
and remembrance practices to comprehend
resist transform and heal
from the patriarchy the racism the
colonization and the history of slavery
and constructing creating and sustaining
spaces for their for their
intersectional realities in gaming
now what does all this have to do with
darius in his opening quote
it is necessary to begin exploring the
contributions of black users through a
framework that i am calling
and it's inside intersectional tech it's
called hybrid infrastructures now i'm
hearing dings i want to make sure that
everybody can still hear me give me a
thumbs up tl if you can okay perfect
now i want to say before we get back to
darius i want to share this other story
on a winter morning in 2014
four black women met digitally in an
online forum to discuss their varied
experiences
within the onslaught of the gamergate
campaign gamergate as most of us know
began as a problem surrounding ethics
and video game journalism where intimate
relationships influence the objectivity
of video game reviews
this quickly devolved into a harassment
campaign against women by mostly men who
were being forced to
accept the inclusion of women and
increased diversity
in-game narratives these four women who
identify racially as black mostly
express their concerns over invisibility
as they recognize that white women's
experiences with harassment were
privileged
these women employed the hashtag
solidarity is for white women borrowing
from mickey kendall's work
on twitter to express concerns on being
ignored while experiencing intersecting
oppressions harassment and hostility
online
on a spring morning in 2015 these same
four women
met physically in new york city to
support a rally for rakia boyd
this movement led to the say her name
campaign a national call
of action for black women and girls who
are victims of police violence
this specific protest that these four
women were a part of
it was heavily criticized for failing to
generate a critical mind
mass it was a signal for some of the
lack of seriousness
seriousness taken of women as victims of
police violence the turnout for that
protest
in contrast to the one for eric garner
in the same city or freddie gray in
baltimore during the same time
reflects the continued devaluation of
black women's lives
as one of the women articulated it's
like we are out of place
like we are taking up too much space our
concerns
and voices are never heard but we show
up and show out all the time for black
men
we're like space invaders until some
work needs to be done
then they call us renisha or tasty
diamond 21 if you read the book you're
going to read a lot from tasty diamond
this point excuse me this concise and
powerful comment was made after the
rakia boyd rally
renisha also known as tasty diamond 21
and xbox live sent this facebook message
message to me uh excuse me sent this
messenger to me while remarking on how
few people showed up to the rally
a stark contrast to the eric garner
rally in this small statement she
uttered a common refrain that black
women hold about their experiences
within social movements of being ignored
overworked and undervalued this example
highlights the continued invisibility of
black women in social arenas
this example also highlights the utility
of multiple modes of communicating and
engaging for black women in public and
private spaces
starting from gaming platforms to their
physical mobility and urban spaces for
protests
i argue that these black women are
reimagining their public spaces creating
intersectional hybrid spaces that
illustrate the fluidicness
the fluidness of their movements from
the digital to the physical and often
back to the digital
while the intersectional transmediated
hybrid
practices in which women engage in
gaming communities reflects the ways
that they create meaning out of
different texts
cultures practices and spaces bridging
multiple to create a hybrid summation of
experiences
so what does darius have to do with this
everything let me go back to his quote
in his short powerful statement darius
articulated not only his reality but a
particular future rooted in digital
blackness and supplemented by physical
spaces
the library in his neighborhood is the
place he can get access to the internet
he figured that out his reliance on
mobile technologies has enabled him to
engage in this
leisure activity but it also connects
into the world and he also shared a
story of not being able to engage in
pokemon go
and so he and his friends had to make up
they made up their own game
utilizing the ar technologies from
snapchat to do so
they also heavily relied on mask an
organization on the south side of
chicago
men and mothers and men against
senseless killing
these women occupy physical space so
their children in their neighborhoods
can move freely
without the fear of violence from moving
from corner to corner
so what kind of questions am i asking
now now that i've put darius at the
center
and making him the expert in his own
life what kinds of questions then should
we be asking
um hopefully you can see that screen
there i'll read here so
i'm gonna i'll switch my energy a little
bit so you know that was kind of like
the book talk this is like gonna
switch gears like until like the future
work but before i get here i want to
also
i want to show you this map i think it's
important that we kind of like
see let me go to hopefully this this is
made bigger on your screen
i need you all to visualize
the space that i'm talking about like
the space that darius resides right
so here i have just like a screen
capture of
a few city blocks right so on the
left um this is the wi-fi map
from chicago chicago touts itself as
being one of the most wired cities in
the united states right
now if you see that little blue dot over
there i'm not sure if you can see my
cursor but that blue dot indicates the
closest wi-fi hotspot the publicly
available
wi-fi in this neighborhood now i didn't
provide the comparison map but if we
were to look on the north side of the
city if we were to look like at
lincoln park or if we were to look at
like magnificent mile or the gold
coast this map would be full of these
blue spots okay
the next map that i want to show you is
also is the chicago the cpl location
chicago public schools
these are um the library excuse me
libraries these are the libraries that
are in the they're sitting in the
neighborhood
now this is a pretty good number of
libraries right so a lot of people you
know often talk about you know how
you know some youth in certain
neighborhoods like don't have access to
the libraries right so we can talk about
them being under resourced and not
having like enough adequate staff or not
having enough like collections and
volumes
that's a different conversation but just
the fact that they have these
libraries in their neighborhood that
they can freely access and go to i think
it's very significant
okay now the next map that i want to
show you is the um
this is the pokemon go stop map right
i'll tell you the significance of
pokemon go but just for right now just
keep in mind this is south side this is
inglewood if you were to look at the
north side of chicago if you
you would see i think i may have a map
here we go
you can see that there is a multitude of
pokey ghost stops
in in different areas of the city but in
inglewood there's just these couple and
it's associated with the park i believe
there's a statue probably a statue that
needs to be torn down to be honest i
don't even know whose this
is but but it's like associated with
like a statue of somebody right
now when these kids were they were they
were talking to me
um whenever i was there again this this
is like some accidental research but it
just made so much sense you know and i i
gave these kids like the space to talk
and what they said was profound they
have articulated their realities like to
a t
right they said that of course they feel
that the the
the fact that they're black and live on
the south side that there's not an
investment into the structures
that that exists like within their
neighborhoods right and so for me i'm
like oh well we can easily just call up
these you know whoever makes pokemon go
niantic we just call them up and figure
out hey let's get some more poke stops
down here right
because surely this is not racism you
know this is not rooted in legacies of
like redlining this is not digital
redlining right this is just you know
some simple neglect right
so whenever we tried to like figure out
how to get more pokey go stops in their
neighborhood
we were told that their neighborhood
probably wasn't ideal because it's not a
safe neighborhood they don't have
sidewalks
um and they they're they needed to have
like this this um
this um idea of safety before they
they just implemented you know these
pokestops right so we felt structurally
that there were going to be some there
were some exclusionary practices
and but they said that if there were
significant landmarks then then this
neighborhood could have some pokey go
stop so
what we this is part of the larger
project that i'm working on we would
have done it this summer but we didn't
but what we wanted to do this summer
was basically say hey there is
significant history here and i didn't
want those
you young folks to feel like that their
neighborhoods weren't valuable and
didn't have anything to offer i'm like
there is significant history here
so we went to the archives let's see if
that if that screen is here
we went we searched up like all kinds of
archives where these
young folks could see that they come
from rich traditions of music traditions
and sports traditions and
you know we found out that you know the
first sears that was in the city of
chicago was on one of the corners like
in their neighborhood
so the students like they were given
like this sense of like pride
you know around their neighborhoods
because all this history had been lost
to them right
and so i think i thought it was very
interesting that we had used like
pokemon go
to like you know revive a lot of these
history and like go through the archives
you know you know um
dig through the crates you know like to
to to so they can see
that they come from like you know these
amazing histories right
um but i want to get back to like the
questions that we're asking and the
questions that these these young folks
really made me start to like dig deeper
and like think about um so
you know some of the guiding questions
that you know that are informing like a
lot of this future work
how do geographically isolated youth
utilize publicly available tools and
technologies to develop hybrid networks
across communities
the their reliance on wi-fi their
reliance on public spaces their reliance
on you know
their these physical spaces needing to
be safe was very significant
and i think that that's something that a
lot of us like digital scholars and
media scholars like don't contend with
enough
you know how important the physical
space still is um secondly how have
these hybrid networks influence and
develop the creation
of culturally sustaining spaces um so
i'm sure like the folks you know of
course you know the folks at niantic are
like are fantastic
but they probably didn't even think hey
when we're deploying these things like
are there do we have to also contend
with like the histories and the legacies
of exclusion and segregation
you know those are one of the things
that they didn't anticipate having to
think about
about how the different conversations
that they would need to ensure you know
equitable access
them across like the cities how do the
culturally sustaining
spaces impact how you develop develop
computational makers
maker practices the fact that these
youth were using these ar technologies
let me
slide over to this the fact that these
youth like
were able to like utilize like these
technologies like they were experts at
it right they had to be experts at it
because there's
there's not like a massive stem programs
that are coming in and like teaching
them how to do all these things
and i think that also comes from like
this deficit model where you know we're
coming in thinking we're teaching these
kids these spaces
i learned so much from these kids i had
never heard of like any of these like
tools that they were utilizing on a
regular basis snapchat was important
wikitude like
holy like i didn't even know what these
things were until they introduced me to
them
and what these youth were doing you know
whenever they were trying to like make
their spaces significant
you know they would go in like tell
stories especially like for them
especially with masses mothers against
senseless killing group like they
develop like beautiful narratives like
with these women because they spent
significant time with these women
um let me know if i'm running out of
time too because i just get really
excited about this and i want to make
sure i've gone off i've gone off the
my notes i'm just talking now so i can
easily just go so make sure somebody
stop me
but like whenever they were just talking
to these women they found out you know
these beautiful stories and these rich
narratives in history
and then so they basically they made the
people like significant
um significant to the space so you know
while we we could say okay this is the
first jazz musician here this is the
first you know
you know mississippi blues you know club
that was here like whatever we do
that that these youth are keeping people
at the center
of what they're doing and really
highlighting the importance of like the
women who are like in
in these spaces i want to finish these
questions because these are really
important questions
what are the everyday activities
informing youth computational thinking
and making practices
and across these different sites you
know from the things that we're doing
here you uic
chicago public libraries and mask what
are the design principles influencing
prolonged engagement with the culturally
sustaining computational maker spaces
i really i think it's important that you
know we we start we have more of these
like collaborative like relationships
um and really i'm gonna be honest i want
to utilize like in my institutional
privileges to give these women some
money like these women are doing
i i wish you know i wanted to have some
video but i didn't i hadn't gotten irb
approval like for that part yeah to
basically show you all this
but you all like should look up like you
know just how mask it's chicago
south side these women put their
physical selves
on the line to so their young people can
play
and i don't think we we take that for
granted like how you know people
who are just excluded and then what
people do to make sure that people
that they can still participate i think
that that's that that's something that
we we don't engage with enough
just a little bit about this future
project that i'm working on
y'all know i've been at multiple
institutions right and i always try to
connect with the communities
um that of these of uh the locations and
the communities that i'm in
um and so i you know starting from you
know working with like
young young folks in the appalachian
region whenever i was at eastern
kentucky
you know basically you know these young
folks these poor white kids are excluded
from from anything that you all could
think you talking about dial up still
some of them may have dial up
there's no broadband there's no fiber
optic watch there's none of this in the
hollers
of eastern kentucky these kids are
excluded but they are still figuring out
ways to like participate and still be a
part
and i think those things need to be
illustrated and highlighted um even you
know whenever i spent you know
my time in arizona you know like
connecting to like you know the yaki
youth and
you know mexican and mexican-american
youth there's this town at
in in phoenix it's called guadalupe now
you would think that you have just
like teleported to like some wild west
past you know there's still dirt
roads and you know there's maybe like a
stop sign like it really just seems like
this old you know town from the wild
west
but these youth are just like okay we're
excluded from a lot of these practices
we're excluded from these stem fields
and these stem camps
you know so we work to bring these
things like to these kids but we went
away with learning so much from them
we didn't teach these kids anything we
were learning so much from them
um and also like with the work that i'm
trying to do like with david david namer
you know working with like the youth
looking at favelas and gabriella richard
you know
you know she's trying to do the same
thing like looking at um like youth in
rural pennsylvania and also looking at
like youth in philadelphia
like this really like we're wanting like
to just to just allow these young folks
to be like experts in their own lives
and just
realize like you know just what they're
able to do you know from these
exclusionary practices i feel like i'm
running out of
out of time i know i am um let me i
think there were a few more slides don't
worry about those slots because i want
to hear from you all
um and especially as like you know i'm
building like this future work and you
know making it making sure that i'm
staying connected to like that the
project of like intersectional tech like
this future you know um this future work
is just really like
um realizing like the potential of like
you know what this work could be and
what
um what what i'm trying to do so i want
to make sure to make space i think
i know we're running out of time i'm
shutting up now okay i'm gonna turn it
over back over to utl
i don't know who gets it i'll stop
sharing right now
that was great you weren't running out
of time it was terrific
i feel like this was over in like 15
minutes so i wanted to make sure
yes oh okay okay you're good all good
oh good okay there's a lot of stuff we
can follow up on
so i think we can open it up um there
are those of you who are
mit folks are in the panelists group and
you can chime in raise your hand
whatever we'll get it going and
those of you who are in the attendees
panel feel free to
toss a question in the q a and we can
get that question to kishona um
i don't know if there's any i can try to
kick one off while people are putting
their thoughts together
i have a question it's a little bit
maybe of a meta conceptual i
i was i found the point you were making
about rage as
praxis and mobilized rage kind of
finding a place for that
in the stories the work we're doing and
i immediately was thinking about
andre brock's interventions now
on pleasure and the libidinal and how we
start
how we can sort of start grappling with
that and i'm just wondering if you think
like
what what does the future of critical
media studies critical internet studies
look like
if we really start taking those
interventions seriously
is it a methodology you know are they
methodological interventions is it
you know conceptual things open up in
different ways
sort of yeah absolutely that's a
fantastic question
i know me and andre we've had like a lot
of conversations around this because i
think we
approach we have the same end goal but i
think how we approach it is like a bit
differently right
you know he's really you know um
inspired by you know exploring like you
know like pleasure and desire and focus
like on joy and
going away from that deficit model you
know i think he would probably root like
a lot of the work that i do like within
this
like afro-pessimism right of how you
know like a lot of like the
the jumping off parts and the jumping
off points of like a lot of my work is
is rooted like in
like sexism racism white supremacy right
and you know and he you know he always
like he he is like pushing my thinking
into thinking
um into like exploring like who
are we outside of like white supremacy
right and i unders i appreciate you know
you know his um his questions and his
challenges like to that
but i often say like as much as i would
like to like look at
you know folks lives and you know their
realities outside
of you know structures of like
oppression and outside of like white
supremacy
um so much of what we do is still is
intimately like connected to those
realities right so it's hard
for me so so i i could easily like you
know turn that off i'm a pretty
privileged person i could like say oh
you know we have these things outside of
that
but immediately like for instance if i
talk to like you know a person like
named darius and you know he
expresses all these kinds of things it's
hard for me to just like ignore that and
say okay
but so what that you had to steal that
phone you've got this you got it now you
know let's just enjoy it and enjoy the
nice things and have joy from it right
like i have to contend with like the
realities in which
you know he is he's residing and then
when he's done with our fancy space and
all the fancy money that we've brought
in and all these fancy things that we
can do
he has to go back home you know to his
neighborhood right
and and so and and i think that it's
it's important to like for me and my
work
because a lot of um you know i don't i
don't
i don't try to say like i'm an expert
like with another of the other folks
the people who are in these in the
projects that are they're the experts in
their own lives they're the narrators
right
and one of the things that they often um
express
to me is like gratitude for giving them
like words and language to express
what's happening around them
right and i think that that's something
that like you know early on like
early in my work like um you know i was
um in these communities you know with
these other black women and they you
know just couldn't understand why
why they weren't accepted in like you
know these spaces and why things
they were being called these words and
they were being like and so
and then i gave them like the language
because it was new to me it was online
disinhibition which is you know like a
framework that i had utilized early in
my work where
where when people say and do things
online that they normally wouldn't do in
person which we know is that's all out
the water now [ __ ]
but but they were so pleased like
learning that and being able to put like
words and
language in and frameworks you know to
what they're experiencing on a
day-to-day basis
me introducing them to like a word like
microaggression you know and it's
something that i'm not teaching them
anything
they know these things but they just
like having just like the language of
helping to like make sense like of their
realities right
but it also like equips them with like
the strengths like
maneuver and to like pivot away and to
like create you know these
alternate futures you know that are like
okay i get it we know white supremacy is
a thing here sure we have
you know jumping off points from like
you know who where what our reality is
especially for like the reality of like
being black in america you know too um
and and so
i i just think that it's it's important
that we just acknowledge that we don't
have to be
we don't have to succumb to the to the
the atrocities associated with the
legacies of like racism and like
oppression
but we can be inspired by what we've
been able to create
in spite of you know and so i think
that's that's
that's the entanglements you know that
that we often you know find
ourselves within especially like in
black media
among black media scholars you know and
and and for me you know
there's nothing that i'm all i'm doing
is making legible the stuff that's
already there
i'm not i haven't created a thing i just
put a fancy word to something that
exists
already right intersectional tech is
just a fancy way so i can continue i'm
just here so i don't get fine
right but i'm not doing anything new
momo pixel is intersectional tech you
know these black women in xbox live or
intersectional today
darius and his dope ass friend who's
larping you know making of like pokemon
go games
they're intersectional tech because they
have cobbled together like pieces of
things that they have access to
and they have like carved out like a
little space for them that's
that's free from from all the things
that they have to experience you know
and i think that's you know that's just
what i want to like make legible to like
academic audiences
why does it matter are we gonna like
transform their lives in like magical
ways you know we probably aren't
right but maybe somebody will give me
some money to make it better for a day
or to like improve their conditions for
day right i'm gonna just be all the way
honest
you know i use language of like you know
transformative potential liberatory
potentials and
you know but i also like recognize like
the limits of that you know
i'm not improving their lives but they
are thankful
that for for one that you know so many
of these kids said you know thank you
for listening to us you know so many
other scholars before me have come into
these spaces and
didn't didn't think that they had
anything to offer
and the fact that you know i'm gonna be
drawn i'm gonna cry like
you know these kids thank me for calling
them experts you know i'm like
you are the expert like you're living
these tough lives and
you've given me a chance just to talk to
you like i'm honored to be able to be
here and talk to you for a few minutes i
just want to make sure that
other people know how dope y'all are
yeah
yeah that's it's it's it's actually a
beautiful
thing way to put it because i think that
one of the things i i really value about
your work is shona
and i mean i'm an ethnographer so maybe
i'm always going to be a little biased
to that but
the way you really do show the
complexity and nuance and
that people have in their everyday lives
without diminishing
the critical structural intervention and
and
and making that visible you as i said i
tried to say you do an
amazing balancing job of those two
things so yeah
yeah thank you yeah i need to stop
crying damn it
you're getting some love in the chat i
know we have oh am i okay
yeah you are and we have one question in
the q a and i just kind of scanning
i don't see a raised hand feature for
the panelists so if there's one of the
if there's an mit person who wants to oh
there is nick
raised his hand okay so and then i'll
and then i'll pull the q a question
after nick goes
hi sorry for not manifesting visually um
that's okay
thanks very much for your talk and i you
know one of the things i wanted to ask
about actually the
the question i have um is related really
to this other um
sort of digital divide uh like
traditional type of media
um and things that are sort of high
culturally ratified and then things like
games
because to me one of the questions is um
not to dictate people's media diets or
what games they play
but you know darius should know about
moa pixels
games and like that that seems to be
like an important connection and
intersection
to be made and one of the issues there
is
when you go into the public library
which is a wonderful resource
and it's black history month there are
books
that are showcased for you you can ask
uh suggestions of the librarian
um you can even get this for other for
comics you can get this or your graphic
novels
you can get those suggestions for um
you know uh dvds although that's
antiquated
these days but uh you know there's
there's lots of media that are made
available and sort of curated
and there's there's suggestions for this
but the librarians are unlikely to know
about video games reflecting
african-american experience
um and so it seems to me like part
part of the issue and actually that you
know one of your contributions here
is making those types of uh connections
and
intersections um that by developing
these lists and raising awareness of
what people do the people like the
game devs of color this weekend and such
um
and taking up the slack from these
traditional institutions
that you're providing more uh awareness
of what's going on
in uh game spaces here um are there
you know how do we further that project
um you know for all sorts of people who
don't know about um the the games
for instance that um deal with their
lives
a fantastic fantastic question nick um
you highlighted a couple things that i
want to make sure to to like engage with
and i think one of the one of the the
benefits of this project
you just reminded me of like the
importance of libraries
right and i think sometimes we take that
for granted you know like even like
in my own classes you know i'm always
like import i'm
uh i always have a project that's built
around like going to the library and
connecting with a librarian and trying
to find like databases right
and i think one of the things but but i
always that always exists outside of
gaming right
you know i never you know i always have
to like you know like identify like a
project
related to like history or something
like more traditional but i think you
you highlight
you know this disconnect you know
between like librarians and like the
things that like some of us do like you
know identifying like the gaming
scholarship and like you know the things
that like youth can engage in
and then it it also like you made me um
it made me think about you know some of
the con
the the like
i don't know if you all know uh liz
phipps soero do you all remember she's a
cambridge librarian she's a librarian at
cambridge sports the kid
the school that my kids went to i love
talking about her
and invoking her name she's the one that
i guess got in hot water
with the dr seuss books you remember she
refused the the the books from you know
first lady
melania trump um but she
unveiled this entire world of like
librarians and like information science
and
how white that space is and i think i i
wasn't like aware of that
so i'm not shocked at the disconnect
like let let me also like fill you in
like on like a little bit of the
background like from
i was only able to like connect with
darius and like his friend groups
because the librarians didn't really
know how to reach them right they were
in that space
but they and then i also need to say
that the librarians were
also trying to get them to always put
their phones away too
right and to like engage in like the
traditional books and like hey put that
away this
that's not reading that's not and so she
was like diminishing
like a lot of what these kids were doing
i'm like and i wanted to say i didn't
want to like you know because my kids
were there just participating i wanted
to be a parent i didn't want to come in
i'm keyshawn i have a phd i know all
that i didn't want to do that either
right
but it let me know that it was important
to establish this relationship
you know with the librarians just so
they can realize like the potential
of of them being able to utilize
traditional library like practices and
to reach like young folks like darius
and his friends right
and then you know so i think one of the
things her initial like response was um
like oh well should i find books that
have like fortnight themes to them or
something like
i'm like sure but but but there are some
games like how about having these kids
make games so twine was the thing that i
introduced her to i'm like okay you want
them to like develop literacy and like
put words together
so you know one of the things that we
did you know during that summer was have
them like make games like utilizing
you know twine like the the text based
game linear you know for folks like who
don't know
and so these were like things that she
really wasn't aware of right so
you know i i i again it's important to
establish like you know relationships
and
and and and get like i said i didn't
want to go in there like you know just
telling her like all these things but i
think it was just important for her to
just kind of reframe her thinking a
little bit
let's not diminish and devalue you know
these them with these games let's try to
use this
as a jumping off point to get them to
reach the point that you're trying to
get them to do
and like creating stories and writing
stories you know i had even like
introduced her to like you know the
the um like even seeing video games is
like an actual text you know so
so like you said you know like nick like
she wasn't even like aware of like the
beautiful
like worlds behind like assassin's creed
for instance you know there's beautiful
narratives inside like assassin's creed
and so it was just a way to get her
you know like to just think differently
you know like about what a text could be
and how we can read different texts and
i think that was um you know you know to
your point i think that was like a
like an important intervention just to
make sure that if i'm not there like i
can't be at every library
you know making sure you know like like
she recognizes that but i just want to
you know i think it's been trying to
like develop like you know have that
relationship
you know with some of the the the
libraries especially the ones on the
south side and west side of chicago yeah
there are other questions my bad did
they answer your question
sorry i just started talking
to your question
yeah he said great together uh maybe
i'll take the i'll read the one from the
q a from one of the attendees so this is
from
thea silvie silviera dr gray thank you
so much for this presentation
how do you think that black women
journalists and communicators could
collaborate
too in this process for more positive
narratives in the media and digital
spaces
and then virtual hugs from brazil they
add
oh yes yes yes yes yes um
that's a fantastic question thank you
for asking that
i had i i don't know i don't
quite know how to do that right i'ma
talk about a recent conversation that i
had you know i won't name on this
person's name but she's like a um
like a journalist like digital
storyteller kind of like person
and you know i think that
that a lot of journalists come into
projects with
an assumption about things already right
so this particular journalist had a had
an idea about
something they wanted me to contribute
to this project in a particular way
but they didn't take gaming seriously
right so you know she's full of like
assumptions about games you know
full of like you know some of the
constructed ideas and images like about
games
and so it the relationship didn't start
on equal
footing right there was not like an
equitable like relationship where she's
like you have something to offer i want
to hear what it is
she came at it from like i have this
particular project i have this story i
got to do
can you help me reach my end goal right
and so
and that that was a problem right you
know because she already has it in her
head and so she's trying to find bits
and pieces for me to fit into this
narrative that she's like created
already
so i think that we have to like take a
step back
that's not the first place that we need
to start where you have this idea and
then you find people to fill that in
i think the relationships have to be
part of like the foundation what
we build you know these projects around
there's another example hopefully you
don't want to say this you know there's
um there's been a story that folks from
abc and good morning america have been
trying to do for like a long time so
i've been in communication with this
lovely person she's a lovely human right
so i've been in communication with her
for about six
years trying to get things off the
ground and so just last week she was
like okay
the producers are finally interested in
doing this like this this expose
on like racing gaming right and the
thing that they want to do
is to like establish is to like do an
experiment
where a black person's like playing a
game and they get called the n word like
they
she wants to to do like that that that
porn thing you know like the thing where
we
like experience you know black people's
pain right
now six years ago seven years ago maybe
i would have been like
okay sure let's do that
but for me that story is old that
story's gone because we know racism
exists in these games already right
but because journalism you know hasn't
really like taken like gaming
seriously you know because like the
moment that they did take it seriously
like on a large scale
you know uh that it was gamergate and
the focus was on like hey let's what's
women's experiences in here they
couldn't even think
intersectionally about how much more
awful like the space could be for women
of color in particular right
um so there was like there have been
like a lot of misses and then like in
this moment of black ops matter they're
like
oh now here we are let's try to like
make sense of like the racism in the
space
now i don't know this is probably bad
for her because the story is not gonna
fit what her producers like the people
at the top thing because they're like
racism is in game how does racism happen
in games they're having basic
conversations that we had decades ago
already right we're beyond that
and and for me i was trying to tell i
was like you know a place that
that might be more generative to have
this conversation is to see how the
technologies have
advanced in a way to protect people from
the harassment that they've experienced
in the space
like i can curate my space i can curate
my stream so that there's a bot
that will you know whip out all of the
instances of racism and sexism i can
protect my space
that's a cool story like what are the
things that people can do to like
protect themselves
the fact that i might be called the n
word or be asked to make a sandwich like
that
that's don't nobody want to do that
anymore so again to get back to your
question about how
i think there has to be like a
relationship and i think it's far too
often
like i said a lot of journalists are
just coming at it with a particular they
have a question that they want to answer
to we all have questions that we don't
want to answer right but i think those
questions need to be
generated in a more collaborative way
right
just like for me doing like a research
project i never go into a research
project with like research questions
again especially if they involve human
others
like if they involve people i need those
people on the other end i want to tell
them hey i'm interested in this what do
you think about that what if you
like so in a more of like more of an
exploratory kind of way
because the minute that i create a
research question i'm establishing a
bias
i am coming at it already from like a
particular place where i think something
in the space and i'm asking the
questions
to try to get me to like that end point
does that does that make sense
i did a lot of talking on there no it's
a great yeah
well the story you're suggesting
journalists tell it's a more nuanced
right and it's
it also gives agency if agency looks
different and
yeah that's right all right kelly kelly
wagman had her hand up
hi thank you so much um
i was wondering it's clearly really
really important this local
like very localized work that you're
doing and i'm kind of curious
how you connect with people on a
kind of broader scale who are doing
similar work in their local communities
kind of like what kinds of tools do you
use to connect and do you feel like you
have the kind of broader support
community and how does that play into
them the
local work um that's a that's a great
question
i'll think about how to how to respond
to that so
i don't go into these projects
with a um with
um assumptions already in mind right
i the first thing i do is just develop
relationships so
people who play games are important to
me and so i try to go to where they are
um of course young folk are important to
me and supporting young folks especially
like black and brown young folks you
know underrepresented youth they're very
important to me
um you know so that's why so whenever
like i was working like in kentucky you
know i just went to where these young
folks were you know
you know the um making connection so
every summer like had a lot i had a
latino leadership camp like through
through my lab where
you know migrant farm workers children
who you know the young folks who were
working
brown youth who were whose parents were
working on like farms in eastern
kentucky you know would come and
you know we would you know just yeah i
would i would just provide them with
like a space
right and i just wanted them to and i
think the
the relationships then informed than the
projects that come out of it
right um and that's like the same thing
that i did like on the south side it was
an accidental
um project you know because i'm just i'm
watching and i guess like seo said the
ethnographer is like we're always like
watching and observing and then just
allowing cultures and people to just
like be and exist
and then we we just figure out ways to
um
to try to leverage those like
relationships sure for our own research
but also how we can like just make those
things like legible to
other people so while this is yes like a
very localized like um
like project i immediately saw the
connections from the things that i was
doing while i was in kentucky
you know to the things that i was doing
when i was in arizona um
and and all those i'm still asking the
same kinds of questions
how are these folks utilizing like
technologies like around them to support
and sustain their communities and what
does that look like
you know i think that question has been
able to travel with me like in
in all these spaces so you know i know
you know there's like these um desires
really to like scale up and i think
that's the thing that you know whatever
i'm trying to get money to support these
projects was tl it's like you don't need
money just do what you want you don't
need money you know she's big about that
right
i want money i just want money to give
these folks i want to give them all
these money i want to take white folks
money that's what i want to do
um but i think you know it's it's it's
really important
that you know like when folks ask me to
like scale up like a project and
how can we like make this um you know
transportable across different spaces if
i create like a
like like a thing can we also implement
this thing like here
and and i think that you know the
ethnographer in me also wants to just
recognize that there is something
special to like localized spaces like
something like the dynamic that's there
you know in that neighborhood in
guadalupe like outside of like phoenix
is different from the dynamics you know
in inglewood in the south side of
chicago and that's different you know
from you know hardin county and kentucky
you know the ho you know
those those things are like different
too and i think it's um the
um and it's it's important that we just
make sure that we
um um approach these projects and allow
um the uniqueness and of these spaces to
stay distinct and to be distinct i think
that's part of like
you know when i talk a lot about like
black cyber feminism which is like a
another project like that distinctness
of like communities is like very
important you know i know a lot of folks
want to generalize and say hey this can
go here but i i like it's okay
you know to have like some some of that
distinctness right um
hopefully that hopefully that that that
answer answered your question
i'm sure it didn't and you're gonna nod
and say yes because you're a kind person
uh somebody else the question i'll read
it there's been a lot of thank you
comments for the talk but i want to read
lisa parks the one she just left
um so it's more comment while people
think of questions if they want to get
in here
thanks kish shona this is from lisa
parks i appreciate how your analysis
highlights the unequal digital
infrastructure across different
communities but at the same time
emphasizes the agency eg
innovation resourcefulness creativity of
black youth
hoping we get their expertise to
challenge the biases and blind spots of
digital elites
your work serves as a crucial bridge
here thanks so much and keep up the
amazing work thank you lisa just didn't
want that to get lost in this couple
days
absolutely other other questions uh it
looks like amber
ambar race
hi uh i was wondering in your
perspective
how can storytellers and cultural
institutions in general
can co-create with their own communities
in order to foster a dialogue about
their public spaces
and improvement i'm glad you asked that
question
i realized as i was reading this talk
that i failed tonight like
the importance of tasty diamond like
from our research she's a streamer
and she calls she considers herself like
a digital storyteller using like just
like streaming technologies
and i think it's just so beautiful how
she has just
has is adamant about the kinds of
stories that she's telling on these
streams right
so i know you know from the amazing work
of you know like tl taylor we've got
like a lot a lot of work away from mia
can sell but we got like a lot of folks
who are like like focusing like on
streaming
um and the the scholarship that we've
gotten from a lot of these places you
know illustrate that
you know a lot of the desires of
streamers are to like build you know
large like you know platforms and they
get followers and to like
you know monetize platforms into like
they're like there's that that
capitalist desire
you know for for that right and i think
that's that's very important
that's very powerful and something that
i've witnessed
one of the um there are
there's a community of black women that
i follow
who have accepted their small niche
status of you know
a variety stream boutique stream or
whatever we we want to call them
and they realize they just said we're
just going to talk about this black
content if people join us they join us
and if they don't then they don't
one of the beautiful things that they do
is like whenever like a game is released
like a cinematic trailer or something
they immediately like connect
you know what they're seeing on the
screen to actual history and actual
like traditional um ways of like
engaging like with content so for
instance i'm thinking about the example
do you remember the the the image that i
had there was a black woman under black
women's rage
um that screen i had that that beautiful
dark-skinned woman
who was like yelling and screaming like
we could we could feel her pain in that
right
well that was part of the cinematic
trailer for assassin's creed
now assassin's creed freedom crime the
downloadable content not like the main
game but it was um
freedom cry where we follow at a wale at
a walley he's a pirate
and he happened upon um uh he was the
story um from the cinematic trailer is
different from the game content but the
cinematic trailer
shows him as a boy shirt from his mom
and sold into slavery
at like a young age and so he was free
he freed himself from slavery
and he started to be like a pirate on
the high seas but he happened upon
you know this small community like in
haiti where he saw the institution of
slavery that was still thriving right
and he said oh hell no i'm not getting
deal with this and he basically took it
upon himself to destroy and dismantle he
killed a lot of white folks right he
destroyed the institutional slavery
and it was like you know like the
precursor of like the haitian revolution
right
you know it kind of gave us like some of
that background but i think that it's
it's really important
how how you know tasty diamond in
particular like utilize like her stream
and connected to other black women
to like tell these stories you know she
said okay a lot of folks are not going
to learn
they're going to go like play this game
and then go read about you know the
different revolutions that happen
you know like in the united states or
north america or south america and so
she said you know
we'll do that work for you you know so
just using that
that game and that cinematic trailer you
know she she talked about you know
different revolutions she talked about
like nat turner she talked about like
the different rebellions she talked
about harper's ferry
you know we learned so much just from
her stream because she said most of
y'all are not getting ready to take no
african-american experience class in
college so i'm gonna do that for you so
that that was a beautiful way that she
was creating like this
this this these um like co-creating like
that that knowledge like with her and
then
the folks some of us who were coming
into the stream you know we were adding
the things that we knew
and it really created you know just
these beautiful spaces
of just like exploring you know like
black history through gaming
and you know like it all like it was the
jumpstart was that cinematic trailer was
like okay you're not just going to plop
down this slave narrative and not give
us any more context or background
right we're going to make sure to like
fill in those blanks and fill in those
holes
and let you know what the lasting
legacies are like
slavery destroyed black families and
communities so we want to make sure just
uh
just to bring that back so i think
streaming is like really like the place
where you can see like a lot of this
beautiful
you know digital storytelling and the
co-creating of like knowledge
um and telling these local life stories
i think you know those are really
beautiful spaces to go see
um i it's it's interesting i just i'm i
was i just recently wrote a piece with
um with my graduate student brian chan
shout out to brian i'm not sure if he's
in this space or not but we were looking
at like the different pathways
um how like black men like for instance
they
a lot of like the most popular black men
who are streamers they have applied that
traditional
like narrative um to their streams they
want to build
huge platforms they want a lot of
followers they do a lot of the
performative kind of over-the-top kind
of thing
hit that like button you know and or you
know like all that kind of stuff they do
like a lot of that performative kind of
thing
like with their streams um and i think
some of them
recognized that they were
trying to apply this template but
because
of the bodies that they're in they would
never be able to reach
that potential um of
like their white male counterparts right
um so
and i think that that hit a lot of them
hard right and some of them
said you know they they're out here
being buffoons and engaging in coonery
and
you know a lot of you all might not know
what those words mean but you know they
were doing some very
you know performative blackness and
stereotypical black kind of performances
like on their streams
and they didn't feel comfortable with it
you know like over time like people were
like expecting
them to continue like engaging like in
this in this kind of practice
like for instance there's one there's
one streamer who he was just
like talking regular he didn't have a
lot of high energy he didn't
and then people were like like you're
not funny anymore you're not engaging
anymore and he was like wait a minute
why are you here he's there and he
realized that he's just entertaining
these people
so that kind of hit him hard like in a
way where he's like you know these
people aren't here for me you know
it's like the entertainment value that
is very important there was also another
streamer in particular
this black this black man he would um
mask his voice when he would go into
these spaces like to talk so
he had a kind of like a chipmunk kind of
like theme going like in his space and
he's funny he's over the top
he he had never in his early streams he
never showed his face but there was one
stream where he did show his face
and then his followers these loyal
followers
like engaged like racism i didn't know
you were a [ __ ] like that's like one
of the quotes like he copied he screen
captured that
and he he has you know he he it hit him
hard because he was like i'm just being
like a funny guy trying to engage in
folks trying to make a few dollars in
this space too
and then but i can't do that because you
automatically think that there's
something different
about me and my content because i'm
black like that
that didn't sit well with him either so
it's really interesting
how like you know like you know we're i
don't know how how we look at like waves
of streaming now
are we in the second wave or i don't
know what i don't know what this is to
you i'll leave tl to like
help us think about things like that but
in this new wave of like streaming
a lot of black men in particular i see
have been have become
have gone more internal and you know
care you know are creating like their
their spaces like for other people like
them
as opposed to you know like the outward
you know front-facing kind of like
kind of things because of the racism
because they realize they they will not
be able to
be equals like they'll never be ninja
you know that's what's not actually
saying
i'll never be ninja i'm like you don't
want to be ninja don't be ninja be
yourself
like that don't be ninja
i want i thought i saw thomas's hand but
now it's gone tomos did was there a
glitch are you
um i think you you answered it but i was
interested in
in um so you you talked about your work
being
kind of look like in the middle of
activism on of course research
and i'm interested if you found out any
resistance um
in either of both spaces you know yeah
absolutely
so i think a lot of folks they don't
they don't set out
with the project of resistance right um
you know so for even um um i know some
folks like the women who you know i
talked about them um meeting up like in
xbox live and then saying hey we need to
go show up to like this this rally like
um to support like rakia boyd and rakia
boyd's family
you know they were like accidental
activists right you know they didn't
intend they were just saying hey
we need to show up we need to do
something even khalif you know khalif
adams you know didn't set out saying
hey i'm an activist like in the space
you know they were just like hey we've
got these platforms we got to do
something we just want to like raise
like awareness
but i think that's how maybe like a lot
of even like activism like even happens
right
you just happen to be at a particular
space at a particular time
you know just think about like the power
for instance that social media have like
in the moments in the death after like
mike brown
right a lot of these people just had
phones they were able to like record
and then they were like okay people are
watching us we'll give you the
information we'll give you the story and
these people you know became the front
lines of like you know a very
significant movement like to advocate
like for black lives right
and so i think that there's although you
know
of course there is you know a lot of
actual like structural actual like
intentional work that's behind
activism too but i think there are a lot
of folks you know who are just
who just happen to find themselves like
so moved by something
and so immersed in something they're
like you know i gotta do something you
know we can't just sit by we can't just
do this so
i think you know that's where it's like
you know a lot of these folks
don't intend to you know engage in like
this resistance you know this activist
work
but it just kind of it kind of falls
into their their lap if you will
um i'm even thinking about like early
early and like you know dissertation
days like you know like around like you
know the late 2000s thing so long ago
i was yeah like 10 years ago over 10
years ago what years is 2020 my goodness
um well like 2008 2009
we were me and the friends that i was
with like we were trying to like boycott
um it was one of the lara croft games
we were boycott i can't remember what
year was all the uh it's
so much time's escaping me now but if
you all remember like the cinematic
trailer
um around one of the lara croft games it
was like alluding to her possibly being
raped in the game right
and we were just not okay with that
framing
and and although you know it was we
didn't generate a critical mass you know
we didn't you know a lot of folks yeah
we're trying to get people to like show
up and like game stuff like on
you know the night that they deployed
the game it's like hey this is awful
we're not going to support right now
we were we were doing the most right but
and i think like a lot of
them from that group you know recognize
like hey even though we don't have the
bodies or the numbers you know we can
still do this work like in other ways
right so a lot of them
have you know gone to streaming now you
know they've developed these blogs and
they've they figured out like other ways
to like utilize their platform to just
like raise awareness
um and i think that those you know those
um all those small scale you know i
think those you know kind of hint at
like resistance like practices and
activism as well
yeah thank you have time for
a few more 30 more questions
from attendees you can throw something
in q q a
bye andrew
maybe in just oh good uh amber
yeah god well if anyone if no one wants
to ask
uh i was wondering like you already
mentioned
that uh in each community is different
uh and you don't want to generalize
right but i was wondering
if uh like what difference did you find
in like rural areas in like cities
and how like if they you'd use different
like the technologies they used in in
different ways uh
to approach and also like how different
it is from the us to brazil for instance
yeah at the rose of uh working yeah let
me start with the second part of your
question
um especially since you invoked brazil
there's a community of black men
um that i've been following for you know
probably since like 2007.
um it was it was um
right after the death of trayvon martin
there was this group of like black men
that were talking about you know there's
their experiences you know their
experiences with police their
experiences were like security guards
and in that group um
they they came to find out find out
later that a lot of them were from
different parts of the world right
you know we found out that you know some
of them like you know from the united
states
some are from uh some lived in puerto
rico some from brazil
somewhere in nigeria some were in um uh
in uh in the uk now
this it was very it was a very
contentious group of folks right now
these are all black men they all
identify like racially as black you know
ethnically you know nationally like
different identifiers and they the
initial conversation was that you know
black men in the united states that
dominate the conversations about you
know black men across the world
and then they like the conversations
were very contentious i remember even
like one conversation where you know
there was a black man that was like
saying like to the black man in brazil
it's like well you don't you
you don't even identify as black only
when it fits you or only when you want
to like engage in like that conversation
around you know like your
your afro you know identity right um
and then there was even like
conversations around like you know like
accents like for the
for the men and and the british men so
they they were making fun like oh you're
british you british
like it was it was really bad they were
like poking fun at one another
but it was like you know some something
happened oh [ __ ] i remember the um
leading up to the olympics in brazil you
know and a lot of the violence
that was happening like to you know
clear spaces
you know pave the way for all these
things that they were building
and then like i think there was a lot of
like police violence that you know made
it to like it made it to
our our media like in the united states
where we're just seeing and then it was
it was a comment that somebody said they
said well i guess the ghetto looks the
same everywhere that was like one of the
comments that one of them made
where they recognize that they they are
dealing with like similar experiences
just you know across the board and that
what what what unifies them was
the blackness their black masculinity
you know kind of like unified
like a lot of their experiences so while
there were you know of course
distinct depressions and distinct things
that are happening you know they just
realize like the similarities like like
among all of them right so
you know i think there will be like like
the the questions that i would then ask
you know some of the men like in
in brazil was different than you know
what i asked like the men the brown
and black men like in puerto rico right
you know their connection to like
legacies of like slavery
like are you even like you know are they
were they even like aware of like the
legacies of slavery and like what's
happening you know
even space in place trying to you know
making the comparisons between like you
know
housing projects like on the south side
of chicago to like the favelas like
you know victoria you know so there are
all these like conversations that were
that were um um that were
that were similar um they were different
but they get us to like similar ends and
like you know similar
um uh uh the end the end is similar
right it's just the pathway to get there
now
there it was very challenging um
the work in eastern kentucky was very
challenging
so i had to like you know like i'm
thinking about the relationships that
you know i was you know trying to build
and going to visit like you know like
like families like you know there will
be confederate flags outside
you know their trailer and you know i'm
trying to say hey you know
can your can your kid participate like
in this in this after school group can
they
come to richmond you know during the
summer you know for a couple days and
like stay in residence in the dorms and
you know i and so i had to like contend
with
what me and this body you know looks
like like in in this space
um it's not to deal with like a lot of
racism you know
um challenging is a nice way to put it
that's right kayla you remember
these stories um i
i there were and there were different
conversations that were had right
but i think that it was all it was
important because i knew
how to use like the language to talk
about like their their class oppression
that was something that the families
understood that they knew and that
it allowed me to start making like the
connections between like class
oppression
and like racial like oppression and like
talk about like the degrees of whiteness
and
you know although i did i wasn't able to
like go as far as i wanted to like with
some of those conversations
but that was also like the moment where
i i incorporated families and a lot more
because i think the work needed to be
done with their families
around um talking about conversations
with like race
um so but i did i wasn't able to do like
as much as i wanted to i didn't have
funding i need money tl to do these
things i didn't have like a lot of the
funding and like the money
like to do a lot of this work um but i
think like a lot of these kids
like i had to tell some of the kids like
don't call me colored okay you don't
have to come please don't call me
colored honey you know
like i had to deal with that but that
didn't stop like the work and then that
didn't stop me from like seeing really
like
the beautiful contributions that these
poor white kids had you know because i
recognize you know just like
you know what they've had to like
experience and endure you know so
that didn't live in me i just realized
that they never had like the pathways to
like understand you know
like all they may be poor but there's
like some white privilege here you know
there's so there was there was a lot of
work you know that that that that i
needed to
to do there yeah i don't know how else
to say that i haven't really like
unpacked
those experiences in a way that i need
to that's a future book maybe that's a
full professor book
it was wild
[Laughter]
i like how you're giving me a hard time
that money
i want you to have all the money trust
me trust me
all right we're almost approaching 6 30.
i don't actually know what our formal in
time is but uh
are there any other questions any
i'm just i can see i'm scanning multiple
monitors and windows
absolutely i'm here i haven't gone
through the chat
at all feel free to look and then i
think emily is raising her
i love it it was like actual physical
hand raise yeah go ahead emily
um i'm just wondering if you can if you
notice
um the people you sort of observe
talking about
uh not just sort of piecing together
different ways of engaging in these
gaming communities but
maintaining their um infrastructural
sort of connection
like talking about um different like
mapping out different
places to find wi-fi or different places
between certain digital devices like how
how did they think about that if they
did absolutely the only reason
why i have um those maps is because i
really just couldn't believe
that there really was no
access right and that it's not that i
didn't believe the kids i think it was
just one of those moments i'm like we're
in the city of chicago like i don't care
that this is the south side this is
chicago
surely you have wi-fi surely you have
these things surely there are pokey go
stops but
i think that was my naivety and like it
was like a crash course that i had to
like you know
acknowledge my own um ignorance around
the the racial politics of the city of
chicago
and you know i'm from the i'm from the
south we have different kind of racism
right
there's not this residential you know
racism you know where
as you know it's it's um i remember as a
kid you know they were like you know in
the south
they don't mind living next to you they
just don't want to work with you
but like in the north they don't they
don't mind working with you they don't
want to live next to you
so i think that's one of the things you
know i got kind of got a sense of this
like
in my time in boston realizing like
seeing real racial
like segregation residential like
segregation
and also like so just being here i'm
just like and in my mind i'm like well
hey kids let's go up to millennial park
let's go up here and like just play
like pokemon go let's just do it
and then just seeing
oh gosh just seeing
security officers whose job it was to
keep them
out of that space that that was kind of
hard for me to contend with right
because i'm like here we are we're not
doing anything we're playing a game
we're playing pokemon go and that was
like around the time where a lot of
people were talking about playing
pokemon go while black and
and talking about like how they can't
just go into like all spaces
and so this was like in the moments this
was like brand new to me too where i was
just like wow
like these these realities are so still
ever present like even even in in this
space so
i think that um i i'm trying to think
about making sure that
that like i i answer your question but i
think that
the the realities like just just
hit me that you know i have to make sure
and again it was an accidental project
you know we were just having fun i'm
like this is giving like the youth like
something to do
but it really you know made me realize
that there was like a lot of like
background that i needed to do
um before i even entered in a project
like i tried to do some but i never want
to do too much where
i'm coming at it with like all these
biases and all these like assumptions
right
um and so i just try to keep um just to
try to
keep that balance of um
of and also you know me being in this
body being an academic researcher trying
to like approach things like in
objective ways which
you know that's not like not true at all
like it's i try i try to distract that
balance i hope i've forgotten like your
question trying to think about
you know just like that that reality too
so hopefully hopefully i answered that i
can't even remember what your question
was emily i'm so sorry
i was really just thinking about in the
moment where the security guard just
basically said
no these black kids can't be here and
they have to go like they kick
they kicked us out they kicked us out
hell even in the place where i live
right now they were trying to kick me
out of like my own
own house because we don't live on the
south side we live on campus right
and so on the campus you know they have
been mobilized to like police black
bodies into
you know if there's a certain time where
you know black people just have to go
you have to get back to the south side
or go back to the west side
and because we were here after hours it
really felt like like sun downtown
like almost whereas like you know i'm
we're not welcome here so
you know i'm married to a big black dude
and i tell them like no you're not gonna
go get that pizza from outside at
eight o'clock at night i'm gonna go down
there because i know security is just
right around the corner just waiting to
like
you know get you out of this space so
you know it's i hope
you don't have to like contend like with
those realities as well i'm sorry emily
did i answer your question
i'm so sorry
i think i i can't tell emily yeah it
looks like she's saying thank you
yeah okay okay all right okay
well you've given us just a heroic
amount of time
and just incredible uh things to think
about and
and the answers to the question so uh
thanks so much kishono give you a round
of applause
um yeah it's been great having you here
to kick us off on a terrific
terrific new year series um
i was just pulling up andrew put a link
to
the our upcoming events and there's two
different things happening next thursday
another of the sessions on deep fakes
and then our colloquium
is justin reich speaking on failure to
disrupt why technology alone can't
transform education so
i think we have another another really
good
kind of critical intervention
conversation ahead so
thanks again kishona um i'll kick it
back to scott if you
i don't know if you have any other
things you want to say to wrap up
no i mean other than just how how
delight i am pleased
and how great your talk was um and just
a word of housekeeping folk keep an eye
out
some of these talks will be live like
this one some will be pre-recorded
if they're pre-recorded they'll be
available at a week before
you'll need to do you'll need to keep an
eye out to see
which is which um if they're
pre-recorded then they'll just be live
chat
at this time of the evening but in any
case uh again thanks everyone
for showing up for a great start for
this program
bye friday bye take care bye all